bismillah alhamdulillah assalamu alaikum
peace be unto you thank you for tuning
in to another episode of the Deen show
we're here every Wednesday Midnight's
Thursdays at 2 p.m. and people from all
around the globe tune into the Deen show
calm if you can't catch us here if
you're not in Chicago you can catch us
at the Deen show calm now we're going to
be getting into our next topic but
before we begin we're going to bring you
up to some current news things that are
in the headlines
federal investigators tested automatic
automated controls for Washington DC's
Metro Transit trains hoping to figure
out why the computerized systems
designed to prevent collisions failed in
a deadly crash this week nine people
killed including the train operator and
more than 70 were injured the Charlie's
Angels star 1970 pop icon Farrah Fawcett
dies at age 62
she was Hollywood's golden girl and now
Farrah Fawcett who epitomized the
American ideal of beauty has died after
three years battling cancer the
television celebrity Ed McMahon has died
Ed McMahon was a successful comedian TV
host who became famous for his run on
The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson he
introduced Johnny Carson with his
trademark here's Johnny and the top news
that we find all over it's the buzz of
the day Michael Jackson energetic seemed
driven by the upbeat of beaten weeks
even hours before his death colleagues
and friends of Michael Jackson's appear
say that he appeared in recent months to
be rejuvenated by his prospect of
performing again he was in great shape
working out with a top trainer getting
in his physical checkups and just before
his death
Jackson was dancing like the old Michael
vote and he died at the age of 50 so
this is the news death which is a
reality as the creator of the heavens
and earth has said in the verbatim Word
of God the Quran every soul shall taste
death so this is a serious event that is
coming we have an appointment with it
and with that said with the news
bringing you up to speed on what's going
on all over the world we're going to be
heading into our next topic with our
next guest Yasser Britt jaws we're going
to be talking about marriage here on the
Dean show we'll be right back
Allah there's only one word Muhammad is
His Messenger
Oh
there's only one Jesus was his messenger
no I did that maybe it maybe it's just
to break the ice
assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullah wa
barakato
how are you sure and a lot of I mean
good to see you again thank you for
coming and being with us on the Deen
show does like a look at it seemed like
when I saw you I told you it was like
almost yesterday you and Allah pleasure
being here with you we were talking
about marriage before again we're still
gonna be talking about it god yes
well before that I know it's encouraged
in Islam that we give some gifts and we
got a nice little gift yes so please
poppy uh would you like to see what it
is I'm sure they would so go ahead and
open it up let them see what the gift
where we got mashallah
you got the Deen show Cup you are thank
you thank you for being with us now
before we get into the topic marriage
everybody should be striving to get
married finding that soulmate which is
encouraging Islam but we talked about
the news we brought this up because it's
a reality we will all face death what
are your comments on some of the things
that we discussed so Paula I myself
actually remember growing up on that
same culture even there was in one of
these Gulf countries but it was a very
interesting actually hitting the news
and I felt like anybody else that it's
just something something that hits
reality reality when in reality when it
hits it just brings you back to all
these now memories of the past how you
grow up and how people they grow up and
so on but eventually no one is really
saved of that event that we can all have
to face it's an appointment regardless
how great you are how great your
achievements were whether you have been
a national international icon or just an
average person eventually have that
appointment with allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala and that shows you what a lot
as i said that there's no escape from
death anyway and I think really I mean
during that time it's definitely a time
for people to reflect that no one can
escape death regardless how much you
think that you're going to survive and
live but it's still it's an event I
believe that it's so important for
people really to think seriously
specifically just like you said you know
there were three icons of this culture
here in America and they all almost
passed away in the course of one week
and that is something really amazing
when you think about it how three of
probably the most amazing icons of TV
shows in America and they all basically
they passed away in that say that that
proximity of time subhanAllah Lost
Planet the plant things in a way that
amazed you all the time yeah it's
amazing how we had mentioned that
Michael Jackson who was probably the
biggest celebrities of pop stars before
his death he was preparing he was
physically in shape he was dancing he
was getting ready to you know put on a
show and that's it exactly
I mean I mean you as the Prophet Salla
son described people with joy when they
plan for their lives they plan ahead of
time all the time not just most of the
time we always plan ahead of time
otherwise we'll never do anything in
life if everybody knows that they're
gonna die next day or the next moment no
one will do anything alive will be this
parade completely but here you see how
Allah spanha without a plan things you
have planned your own life for the next
and extra time that's our extension what
a lot of fun planned that your
appointment with him will be closer than
that as a prophet sallal I am says
usually Adam he's always have total Eman
told I much means that long hope for a
half or a longer life so when people
they did it they basically they planned
things it goes beyond their circle or
their basic appointments of what Allah
Spano Madonna but then as they planned
then a larger bring everything to
interrupt all these let that all these
beauties and all these pleasures of this
dunya couple more points should people
feel sad about this is this called a
pessimism then when we talk about death
no as a matter of fact it should be a
motivation because if you know that you
live in one life and that you know that
you have an appointment at last Panama
data you can have to prepare for it
that's the whole idea
some people they're just completely
negative all the time and therefore when
I think of death they always take that
negative side of it
meaning if I'm gonna die why should I do
anything that yeah may what's the
purpose of doing anything no death
should be a motivation and that's one of
the things in Islam Sao Paulo even the
concept of prohibitions like for
instance the prohibition of alcohol in
Islam the prohibition of
for adultery and fornication and so on
all these things for some people who
would like to indulge themselves an
immersive themselves in pleasure they
think these are as obstacles but for a
true believer they're not obstacles they
as a matter of fact there are challenges
so that you overcome you know the
reality of life these prohibitions by
something that's it's it's pleasurable
pleasurable but the same time is
permissible yeah so if you don't drink
alcohol for example there are so many
other things that you can enjoy you know
life without drinking a sip of alcohol
if you cannot commit adultery or
fornication loss you have blessed you
with that with the ability to go and
select a spouse and and your life
together that is the same thing it's not
an obstacle it's not something to cause
people to get completely desperate and
start you know stopping living their
lives no usually it should be a
motivation it's only one life that
you're going to be living so you better
do it for allah subhanho wa taala
and you prepare yourself for that event
the entire lifetime so when you're dying
at least you're ready that you have done
your best insha'Allah Allah now we're
the only Islamic program on the cable
station can TV in Chicago so we have a
lot of non-muslims listening and you
said something in Arabic you said Allah
and you followed up with subhana WA
Ta'ala can you please translate what you
said when you say the word aloud means
basically God we're talking about God
and so and Subhan Allah means that glory
to Allah or praise praise be to Allah
usually as Muslims when you speak the
order philosopher named Allen which we
speak his name we always say all praise
to Allah and all glories to Allah and
that's why when he said the word
subhanAllah so usually becomes natural
as you speak it becomes part of your of
your language all of the time and that
keeps you always you know attached and
and conscious about your actions your
reward your speech and you always think
of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala in general
can you give us some attributes of this
crater that we worship also because
there's a lot of misconceptions people
that might think that we worship a moon
god or some people worship a man
somewhere people worship the creation of
the Creator can you give us some
attributes of this law that we worship
actually this is one of the major
misconceptions about Muslims you know
people say Muslims they decide the moon
during the month of Ramadan and people
they keep talking about sighting the
moon and side in the Halal and so on and
when you go to some Islamic centers and
some mosques here in America and
elsewhere in the world you see this also
this icon
is that the croissant yeah so when you
say the crescendo people they think also
mostly most likely a worshipping that
the moon God and that's done with the
major misconceptions it's it has nothing
to do with worshipping the moon God and
this is just like a fable or some kind
of old stories from from from way before
Islam predating Islam Arabs just they
were policies they would worship so many
God and so many idols and so on but when
it slime came came to prohibit all these
all these acts of worship so his is one
and the only one and he's in heaven
subhanahu wata'ala in the seventh heaven
so when you worship allah sojourn we do
not worship we do not set any partners
with him and that's very important for
us so the idea of even thinking of
another God what are you call him moon
God whatsoever this is this is a not an
act of disobedient and act of polytheism
you don't believe in that as muslims so
and that's a misconception because of
these icons that muslims they use the
only reason they use the crescent or the
moon it's because it's just it's a sign
of calculation almost actually all the
traditional cultures and civilizations
they use the moon for calculation and
they have their own calendars so muslims
also they follow the same the same
concept and the lunar calendar basically
i'm going to use the lunar calendar
you'll be following the calculation of
months based on sighting the moon or the
crescent that's how it came about to
become again islamic I could only but
just you know a sign that they use you
know as a reminder for these months
gotcha okay so with that said now people
can read a little bit more about you
because you have an impressive resume
you studied at the prestigious Medina
University and you're a one of the head
instructors at Al Maghrib University and
also you are the the owner of the and
you run this practive eight
co-founder co-founder of practive eight
yes okay so we're gonna have your own
little biography and everything that
people can see at the Dean show calm
under our guest section but now we want
to get into some of these questions that
people have marriage it's it's something
that you know people look forward to and
it's something that's really encouraging
Islam so we have some some questions
here that people are asked
and we want to talk to you because
you're the master Fick
what does Fick mean actually that means
that jurisprudence or Islamic law yeah
now when you say it's the basically that
the rules of Islam in general Muslims
they live they live their lives by an
organized system yeah of moral and
morality and ethics yeah so these are
part of the Islamic system and part of
what we call it the filter so when you
have Phil coughs allow it means that the
law of prayers how to perform the salah
so the Civic etiquette that needs to be
followed so you have v of marriage same
thing the etiquette of getting married
and so on so they go by that because we
believe being the creation of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala we need to live by
his laws and his rules and he knows what
is best for his creation so when he says
these rules we definitely have the full
trust and confidence that brings that
the best tool to mankind gotcha okay
let's get into the questions now let's
go for it everybody's excited they want
to know it want answers to these now
first question is brothers asking I
think it's coming from her brother he
says there's a sister who I'm interested
in for marriage and I think she has the
same feelings towards me
how do I confirm this without crossing
any lines no this is one back to the
trickiest way if you know doing things
because Muslims do not believe that in
dating and they they believe that there
should be some kind of guidelines
whatever to interaction between men and
women yes
and so therefore if someone has some
feelings let's say towards a lady and
he's interested genuinely near in
approaching her and he would like to go
and pursue that in the most that a
permissible way which is go for marriage
definitely yeah the best way of doing it
is to go and uncheck Dana if he knows
for instance some married couples or
mark people yeah whom he assumed that
his friends wives they know that lady
that they bring him more information
about their availability and so on so
they told him that she's available for
somebody that means she's not engaged
he's not married and so on and then in
this case he can send some informal
let's say show of interest that this
gentleman entered
and in this case if she saw shoe if she
shows similar interest then he goes to
the formal
talking and and and discussion and
knowing it to get to know each other and
so on but if they receive that's a
negative response that she's not for
example available she's engaged already
or maybe she's not ready at all because
using she's doing her school or
something like that then in this case
the person should not really put too
much energy into that because it's gonna
be consuming so better just you know
call it off and thought you know going
on with their lives okay you're at a
convention let's give some kind of
practical example yes tell us what would
be the role what advice can you give you
had a convention we know that the male
the female he should be lower than their
gaze and but you're looking around and
just something gets caught in your eye
and your glance and you see each other
and you say wow I need to get married
and she might be the one okay now you
got your sister possibly with you or
maybe a friend
you don't want to let this opportunity
go you want to seize the moment can you
seize the moment
a can you do something allow that you
can maybe send your sister or someone
else to approach her or maybe if you
don't have a sister of someone else with
you that you can try to approach that
person to ask for her guardian
absolutely I mean as long as it's done
in the most respectful manner yeah then
it's okay so the best way of doing it
basically which is the tradition of the
most efficient way is if you have your
sister with you or a wife of a friend
who can approach that lady for example
again and give it an informal request or
phone basically what we call football
which means just like a request of
engagement if there was any chance for
that this is the best way of doing it
and even better off if if you know the
the parents of the lady because
eventually in traditional families and
Muslims they value actually traditional
values of families they would like to
have their parents be part of their
marriage yeah and they would like to
they would be proud to have their
parents you know being part of their
night so therefore if you know their
parents and you can have someone who
talks to her mom or even you going to
talk directly to her dad for example
they'll be they'll be even much better
because that shows the man how
respectful you are that you would not go
let's say you know on your own
son it's not make me though what if
someone wasn't in this kind of moment
and there was nobody at the time to to
do that for them yeah can the person go
directly and let's say talk to the
person that was going to be actually my
next question basically islamically yes
a man has a right to propose directly to
a woman and but this is based I would
say on the general general ambient and
environment of that locality so this is
something kind of offensive to some
families and they don't like that
because it's kind of you know crossing
the lines even though Islamically it's
okay that's permissible as even remember
hotmama' bhai rahim allah wahda
mentioned that in Asahi even a woman can
even propose to a guy directly provided
that they have the genuine intention for
marriage means the person is really
really ready it's not that it just you
know they're so someone and they just
now the moment of of love and this you
know what I don't want to lose this
opportunity yeah it's not about just
losing an opportunity are you ready for
that opportunity if you're not ready for
the opportunity then you're doing the
wrong thing right yeah so if someone for
example broke he's not even finishing
his school he has no job
he has no accomodation he lives with his
family and so on how do you expect this
person to go and propose officially I
mean people they would say the first
thing they would ask about is who's your
family you know are they okay with that
are you ready for it are you prepared
for this so people did before even they
took that chance to start you know
looking around in this case they need to
be first ready for it so if the brother
let's say the brothers ready he's got
some money in the bank account yeah he's
got a place where he can take his new
wife yes maybe even he's even living at
home and his parents are seeing that
look we need to safeguard our child from
her you know fornicating so they're kind
enough to say look you can you know be
in the room and get you your own room
live with the family until you you know
get your own place it's permissible to
pass so now he can actually go up at the
Masjid or the convention somewhere and
now the process um if I'm correct he
said see her before you marry her yes so
now can he actually get a nice look and
say or does he have to lower his gaze
these are practical issues this is a
cookie now can he now like should he say
like okay I
just happened to see you I wasn't
supposed to be looking but I look cause
I'm trying to get married
and or should he be looking at it what
she talked well the point is is if the
person has he's already ready yes one
thing but will you say ready first of
all let's define that okay but the
meaning of being ready
most people they look at the guys the
person I mean when you say ready we talk
about the man yeah because we believe
that the man is responsible to provide
for the family
mm-hmm even if the woman even let's say
the lady she's also a financially
independent and she has her own job or
career and so on still though you know
in the mind of so many people being
ready for nice means the man who is the
one should be responsible for that and a
woman she keeps her money for herself in
general unless they have specific
arrangements yeah so the man needs to be
ready financially being ready
financially involves two two sides of
that preparation usually you have the
initiation initiation of marriage and
then you have the continuation of
marriage the initiation of marriage is
probably the most difficult financial
burden why because many people living in
the end American culture here
they started demanding so much in order
to allow this to happen
yeah so they request so much for the
dowry what we call it my heart in the
area now which is a bridal gift so they
asked the man to provide such amount of
money that it's might be beyond let's
say capability or this may be considered
all their safe it's unreasonable
exactly and then they demand also that's
a specific lifestyle instead of
apartment they need a house instead of a
house they might need even a mansion or
something like that even they when they
demand so much from the person yeah that
they become overwhelmed and they get
turned off sometimes yeah and I went to
unfortunately many many young men and
women their families in particular they
they consider this and measure for their
social for the social status means the
higher that you ask for means the higher
your social status and you don't ask for
that much people distinct they you know
what they just give another kids for
nothing I mean it's it's not about
showing the status you don't show your
status by doing that and that's why they
pay so much money for what they call it
Malema
which means that the wedding party and
the wedding night and all these things
and so on the the kids once they're done
from all these preparations right now
they're already in debt and they have
also other debts for that
so the basic
it's really overwhelming the second
portion of preparation is actually a
continuation of manager which is once -
now you're done with their marriage and
with the wedding party now can you live
together on your own if the person has
the capable at the financial capability
of sustaining a living an apartment at
least or living with their family if
they have specific arrangements for that
and then he can provide provision you
can provide let's say the decent life
and so on then this person is actually
ready for that so that's the meaning of
being ready and prepared financially
yeah when people they assume you already
if you have a stable job yeah so when
you're still in school for them the this
is not this is not a sign of maturity
yet you have to finish your school first
unless again you have a preparation or
arrangement with the family that they
will help them of course financially
doing that so that's the meaning of
getting ready actually for marriage so
now the brothers ready he's making his
salat he's implementing this way of life
and of total submission to the crater
alone and he's wanting to do things
right he doesn't want to fall into
tricks and traps that are out there of
dating boyfriend and girlfriend he wants
to do things that are pleasing to his
creator hey now tell us because we want
to also talk about this place where is
the halal hookup get married do it the
look the the right way practive eight
tell us what is the halal way we have
another question we've spent a lot on
this one but what is now the halal way
to go about proposing to a sister or to
a brother well when you say to halal way
it means permissible way means Islamic
as you said there was a guideline yeah
there between that that separates you
know that the permissible from
impermissible yeah when it comes to
interaction between men and women one of
the things that comes also from the from
the previous question is when someone
wants to propose did he look should you
look down and so on yeah
now once the person is ready means they
are qualified to going to put qualified
yeah so once they become qualified to
propose then you have different means of
doing that some of them are traditional
some of them are cultural some of them
are just general you know Islamic when
we say cultural because we live in a
multicultural society there is no one
defined culture for Muslims here and the
common one for the younger ones
specifically the younger generation is
the American culture and we say American
culture
kind of hybrid between the personal
culture that comes from their
forefathers as well as the Islamic
interaction here in America so they have
modified some of their culture for
example so usually in the most common I
would say the most initial societies
among Muslims it is unknown for a guy to
go directly to propose to a girl yeah
it's it's kind of difficult to basically
to accept by the older generation but
the end of generation they have no
problem with that because now they're
already going to school together they've
probably been participating some
activities some conferences some even so
many actually programs that they share
together so then what's the big deal to
go and talk to her if you think that she
is maybe the one yeah
Islamic Lee there is nothing wrong
provided that the person is really
interested genuinely in marriage it's
not just a matter of hanging out until
school is over semester is over and so I
know this is not acceptable at all but
if someone is generally interested and
they go directly to the girl and I said
I would just wanna let you know that
I've let's say I have a genuine
intention charlotta delusions permanent
the permissible way and I'm interested I
would like to know if you can I talk to
your frozen food number for a father
Oh to your mother or even to if she
doesn't have let's say she's a convert
and she has let normally who can or a
guardian who can speak on her behalf of
help her with that he can directly to
propose to her and I'd asked he says I'm
really interested I would like to do to
show them the permissible way and I want
to know what you would like to say about
this yeah or if you would like to think
about it maybe you know have me talk to
somebody on your behalf or maybe someone
that you would like me to to go fish
alia proposed to and so on eventually
there are so many ways of doing that
yeah sometimes if it goes through master
through families many people day they
they misinterpret the world arranged
marriage and they think that you know
people are forced into it yes there are
people unfortunately who are forced into
marriage and being forced into marriage
Islamic Lee is wrong yeah and as a
matter of fact it invalidates even the
contract
yeah but culture sometimes prevails over
the over Islamic
practices because Muslim they don't not
all of them live by the beliefs and the
etiquettes of Islam some of them they
have the culture above unfortunately
what they believe in to be right or
wrong our culture just creeping up miss
Lama absolute so this is the thing that
confuses many people when you start
hearing about things like that so family
arrangements sometimes the guy he trusts
his mom's judgment the girl she trusts
her parents judgment and so on it's okay
whatever it is if you think is okay I'm
okay with that
yeah why because they would like to have
the family support that doesn't mean
that she's not gonna sit with him
doesn't mean that she's not gonna talk
to him or he talks to her they still
gonna come together and talk and
converse and see things for a first hand
and eventually once they feel
comfortable with each other there is
that comfort zone take of the decision
yes okay oh it's okay I'll take with
that
does it work all the time not
necessarily
yeah even in the dating culture doesn't
work all the time so there are no
guarantee basically whether it's
arranged or not arranged in this case
and so on there are no guarantees that
this is going to be successful
relationship because at this success of
marriage it has a lot of dynamics and
elements into it it's not about just you
know the beginning of it it's also the
continuation of the relationship yeah so
the choice is one thing and then how to
work out after all the way different
thing tell us now let's spend a few
minutes before we come to an end here on
the Dean show with Sheikh yasser bridges
i couldn't pronounce your name before
you remember that I remember so now you
have this practive a hookup halal sau
get married do it right with some
training yes
talk to us about this well the idea of
practice which stands for practice
practical practicing Muslims is is a
kind of solution that we try to provide
for those young men and women who live a
culture that is kind of foreign you know
to them at some point and some of it is
kind of they don't want to do something
wrong that displeases their Lord and
their creator so they wanna do the
proper way how to get to to know someone
for marriage yes and we believe that
personally actually as an instructor on
with another Institute and teaching
classes on filth of love and love notes
and the dedicated marriage and spirit of
marriage in Islam and so on
I have seen so much going around in the
Muslim community here
and the young ones they're kind of lost
because they think one of the myths of
marriage is that I think Matt is natural
means everything's gonna be okay because
everybody's doing it so why should it be
different for me then yeah so I can
manage I don't I don't need really any
training specifically guys guys they're
so proud of themselves which is the
masculine ego and they're so proud of
themselves that they think you know what
I don't really need any training
I don't want anybody to tell me how to
get married yeah well guess what in the
20 21st century
you need that you need some absolutely
because you need someone to tell you how
to go about things in order to ensure
that you have success in that
relationship practive eight came out
actually in order to solve this problem
and we started by starting the marriage
revolution calm the marriage revolution
commish was like a blog we started you
know a brainstorming with many singles
men and women and try to to bring ideas
and suggestions what exactly they think
about one two three four and so on
eventual what do you need to know about
marriage all these things and from their
feedback we designed practically to help
devising specific training of course
we're still in the early stages of that
and we're doing our best to provide them
with the best thing that we think it
would be helpful to them and shot in the
future we don't believe we were perfect
but we're trying to our best to help to
help with that and Charlotte Anna and
we're sure that if we keep going on and
continue things will be better in
Charlotte Allah in the future part of
practically we have matching also
services and that would that matching
services we're trying our best to make
it the the most respectful way and
without crossing any lines again we're
not perfect in that in that either but
we're still trying to provide a service
that we hope there will be Charlotte are
very beneficial to the young men and
women in the Muslim community are you
prepared because there's a lot of
singles out here and they're ready to
get married so you prepare for all these
newcomers that are going to come aboard
bismillah I would like to invite
everybody to give it a try just come to
our website just connect teammate calm
or the marriage Revolution to start you
know their conversation and dialogue
with other singles and from there in
Charlotte they can make the decision
would like to join us or not and we wish
them the best
shake thank you very much you're welcome
for being with us jessica ojeda
thank you very much and thank you for
tuning into another episode
of the Deen show in the beginning we
talked about deaf people who have died
this is something that should be on our
minds our appointment that we have don't
hesitate and put this off another moment
start to dig if you already haven't
found the truth start to dig for it just
as you would not put off cashing that 1
million dollar check they had an
expiration date on it you'd be running
in a hurry to get that money there's
something even more important our
appointment with death and some of these
people that were with us they're no more
no longer with us so this is something
as the Sheikh was saying something that
we should be optimistic about motivated
to do the good that our creators told us
to do and one of those good things is
getting married a worshipping him alone
worship the in the Creator and not his
creation and doing everything and one of
those important things is finding your
soulmate in Islam so you can visit the
sheiks website at practice make com if
you're looking for that special someone
get that proper training and do it for
Lao style do it the right way
and we hope that we get to see you I
mean we hope that you visit us again
here on the Dean show until next time I
sellout alaikum peace be unto you
come let's see what everyone's talking
about who if you find one contradiction
it can't be from God but the rational
idea the rational explanation is you do
your best to give up for spring guidance
I will never give up spreading this
message okay you take that necessary
step you don't know if you're gonna live
till tomorrow
so you got to find that urgency to do
the right thing right now the reality of
life usually that you sink in until
tragedy comes you get a few bad people
the media grabs a hold of that and
spends it the way they want to if you
say that you're not believe in Jesus you
have stepped outside of it's none you
cannot be a Muslim is that ended our
faith - I still AM what a cool piece be
going toward you Peabo kickback relaxes
your chill up with the Dean show God's
will it you're living it every day at
night so listen let me tell you a bit
about envoy your flight it's lame the
true religion every proper teachers I
don't know what Abraham Moses even Jesus
is called to worship the one true God
and that's the base of the slab let me
let her get along brothers everywhere
all around the globe coming to drop a
bit and knowledge from the comfort of
your home so ladies and gents brothers
and sisters get ready you're watching
the teen show take it away
Eddie